I'm not here to murder bend the knee and
join me or refuse and die you need to
find a way to make a listen but if it's
done in a way fool defeat once or the
knight king and his army marching
towards each water
about things are cool what's up ladies
and gentlemen welcome back for my Game
of Thrones Season 7 trailer breakdown
video now that episode 4 is behind us
it's time to look forward to episode 5
so let's go through this trailer
scene-by-scene
and i will tell you everything that is
going to happen next most of you that
are longtime subscribers of my know that
i have read the plot leaks that are
accurate and i have also made videos on
all the set photos the casting news
filming news and pretty much everything
else that has to do with Game of Thrones
so I have a great idea of what's going
to happen throughout the entire season
so I will be using everything available
to me and I'll keep this breakdown very
simple so proceed with caution because
there will be spoilers in this video
shall we begin
the trailer opens up right after the
battle has ended Daenerys was victorious
against the lannister and Tarly men and
now she is giving the remaining
survivors an opportunity to join her
side or die she tells the survivors that
she is not here to murder bend the knee
and join me or refuse and die Jaime and
Bronn will not be here because they most
likely floated down the river a little
bit to safety but Randall and dicken
Tarly should be here we did not see them
die or make any kind of escape during
the battle so if Daenerys could get them
to bend a knee right here and join her
cause this would be another big win for
her because it would subtract one of
Circe's big allies right now obviously
the tarly's are very low on men but
Randall could still be used for his
battle tactics and the wars to come but
Randall was never going to bend a knee
to Daenerys and this will get him and
his son burned alive Daenerys will be
making an example out of them then the
rest of the men that are standing here
will probably bend the knee so they do
not receive the same fate you can
clearly see that Tyrion is very
conflicted about this decision obviously
Tyrion as a Lannister so he doesn't want
to see other Lannister men get burned
alive especially since Tyrion probably
fought with some of these men during the
Battle of Blackwater Bay Tyrion also has
no idea whether Jaime is alive or not so
now he's very concerned about the
direction their strategy is going in he
is afraid the Narus is going to cross
the line and get two bloodthirsty but
after she proves her point here Tyrion
will learn that Jaime is still alive and
he's going to try to get Jaime and
Cersei to give up before anyone else has
to die in the next scene you can see the
dead
and destruction littered across the
battlefield the horrors of war is not a
pretty sight and if you look closely you
can actually see two men walking across
this battlefield I do think this will be
Jaime and Bronn after they get out of
the river because when the last episode
ended it appeared like Jaime was going
to die because his heavy armor was
sinking him rather quickly but as we all
know bran does not wear armor he
typically wears his badass leather
jacket so he will probably help Jimmy
pull off his armor that way he can get
to the surface of the water then they
will probably swim or float down the
current to safety and wait for everyone
else to leave that's why I think this is
them walking back and witnessing this
horrific graveyard of mostly Lannister
and Tarly men they will both make it
back to King's Landing by the end of the
episode because we can hear Cersei
talking to who I believe is Jaime later
in this trailer next there is a scene of
Tyrion and Varys and Varys tells
terraeum that you need to find a way to
make her listen and there are two
different ways I actually looked at this
Varys could be talking about Daenerys
right here and her using and wanting to
continue to use her dragons to burn
everyone alive but Varys could also be
talking about Cersei here you can see
that Tyrion is now drinking again and he
looks like a complete mess Tyrion
probably feels like a complete failure
right now his strategies have not worked
out for him and his family is on the
verge of being burn alive Tyrion is
being absolutely ripped apart inside
because there is obviously a conflict of
interest with him on one hand he wants
to help Daenerys because she could be a
better ruler than Cersei
but on the other hand he doesn't want to
see his brother die in the process
Tyrion will have to make a very tough
decision Tyrion will go to King's
Landing with Davos and as we all know
Davos was a smuggler so he could
probably sneak carrion in without
getting him spotted and arrested so he
can meet and speak with Jaime Tyrion
will ask Jamie to get Cersei to bend the
knee to Daenerys but we all know Cersei
will never do that Jaime might even be
pissed off himself after seeing so many
of his men get burned alive Jaime is not
about to abandon Cersei just yet we then
get a scene of Daenerys arriving back on
Dragonstone after just wanting the
battle and she flies right up on John
with gurgaon and bring them face to face
John will finally have his first
physical interaction with the dragons
and Daenerys was being a little bit of
recive would drug on probably trying to
intimidate John a little bit but she's
going to be in for a pleasant surprise
drogon will be putting his face right up
to John's face and John will reach out
and touch him and Jovan is going to let
him the bonding between John and the
Dragons will have officially begun
and Daenerys is going to be a little bit
surprised by this she has no idea that
John actually has the blood of a dragon
as well and seeing John get comfortable
what the Dragons will probably be really
cool because one day we might need him
to ride one of his own to take down the
army of the Dead next there is a scene
with Cersei telling someone that no
matter what stands in their way they
will defeat it and I think she is
talking to Jamie right here
I believe he makes it back to King's
Landing and he tells Cersei everything
that happened during the battle and she
is still confident that they can win
this thing
randyll Tarly did say that the gold made
it back to King's Landing so she's going
to use that gold to pay off the bank and
she will get herself a large sell sort
company Jaime is also going to tell her
that they were actually able to hurt the
dragon and bring it down although it
didn't killed Rogan Cersei will have
Qyburn get some more ballistas made or
possibly even some other kind of anti
dragon weapon the Lannisters and
Harley's were defeated in that one
battle but what the gold Cersei can
still strengthen her forces and fleet
and have more weapons made that's why
she is so confident still because she is
nowhere near out of this fight just yet
and if one of Danny's dragons gets
killed
that will put Cersei in an even better
position the power struggle between
Daenerys and Cersei will be a 12-round
fight to the death they also show us a
quick clip of Qyburn and Cersei alone
together in another room and there are a
few different things that may be
happening right here Cersei can tell him
to make sure the cell swords are on
their way since we did learn that Qyburn
had already been in negotiations with
them during the scene with Cersei and
Tyco she could also be telling Qyburn
about making some more weapons to kill
the dragons or Cersei is being examined
by Qyburn because she is actually
pregnant believe it or not Cersei will
be pregnant again but the baby will not
live because the prophecy told to her by
Maggy the Frog said that she would only
have three kids she might get pregnant
again but it will not survive the
pregnancy further proving the prophecy
to be accurate this could potentially
drive Cersei even further into madness
if she loses another child
but we will have to wait and see how
that
but we did see Cersei and Jaime getting
ready to have sex so the chances of this
are very high next we go up to
Winterfell where brains dark is sending
out all of his Ravens to spy on the
night Kings army so he can track their
movements and I actually guessed this
right during my trailer breakdown I said
this was going to be the army marching
to the wall and bran would see it and if
you look closely at the army of the Dead
you can actually see the night King and
his taut lieutenant White Walkers on
their horses there is a scene from the
trailer that shows the night king
looking up into the sky then it showed
bran stark snapping out of his vision
the night King might look directly up at
the Ravens and he will know that it is
brain stark and this will cause bran to
snap out of it the night king could also
be looking up at a dragon because
Daenerys will eventually take her
dragons up there to help John the night
king and his army are currently marching
to eastwatch-by-the-sea and this is
where they will breach the wall in some
way and get south the hound solvus in
his visions in the flames he could see
where the wall meets the sea and he saw
the army of the Dead marching past a
mountain that looked like an arrowhead
the Brotherhood and the Hound maybe at
Eastwatch already warning everyone about
what's coming and tormund should also be
there since jon told him and the
wildlings to go and man the wall Jon
will also be taking his own group of men
here all of these amazing characters
will go beyond the wall together to
capture a white because Jon is still
trying to convince everyone about this
threat he will think that in order to
get the support that he truly needs he's
going to need to get physical proof
that's why we have seen all these
characters together far up north
fighting the dead but before John leaves
Dragonstone you can see him here holding
a meeting telling everyone about bran
seeing the night king marching to
Eastwatch this is when Jon will decide
he needs to go to eastwatch-by-the-sea
and help for himself but he isn't going
to be going alone when Tyrion and dad
let's go to King's Landing to meet with
Jaime Davos will find ginjury still
making weapons and in this trailer you
can actually hear Davos say bad things
are coming he might actually be telling
this to Gendry to get his help now that
Jon has all this dragon glass at his
disposal he could really use someone
like Gendry to make them into weapons
back in season 3 games we planned on
staying with the Brotherhood without
banners to make weapons for them so he
might actually decide to do the same
thing for Jon Jon we'll be getting a
letter from Winterfell telling him that
Aria and brainer
this could also persuade Gendry into
helping John if he knows that aria is
his sister Gendry wasn't willing to help
her brother Robb Stark but he might
change his mind and actually help John
during these very dark times Jorah
Mormont is also going to show up in this
next episode now that he's cured from
his greyscale and him and Daenerys
should have a nice reunion together but
Jorah will volunteer to go and help the
north in this situation Jorah will want
to make things right again Ned Stark was
actually going to cut his damn head off
for selling poachers in his slavery so
he might want to make things right by
helping out John and he will also want
to do right by Lyanna Mormont I'm not
actually sure if we're going to see John
and company arrive at East Watch in this
episode but they will leave Dragonstone
and head straight that
eastwatch-by-the-sea to meet up with the
other men to go beyond the wall this
should be a very exciting episode as all
the tension continues to rise the war
between Daenerys and Cersei is just
getting started
but now there is a much bigger threat in
the north making its way to south which
is going to force Daenerys to make a
decision does she stay and continue to
try and knock Cersei off the Iron Throne
or does she hope John and the men in the
north to fight back the army of the Dead
I am getting so excited for these last
few episodes now that things are really
starting to intensify so let me know in
the comments section if there was
anything that I missed during this
trailer thank you all so much for
stopping by and watching today's video I
really do appreciate that and I hope you
all come back for the next one and I
also want to thank my patreon supporters
who continue to show their love month
after month thank you all so much I will
see you in the next one bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you